لقد قلت مؤخرًا أنه يمكننا السيطرة
على الوباء الطمع الذي قلته إنك تأمل بحلول
العام المقبل
كيف نحصل على المزيد من تغطية اللقاح
بمرور الوقت
أه وأنت تعلم لذا
يجب أن تنخفض ذروة التأثير
قليلاً وسيتعين على كل مجتمع أن يفعل  إن
المقايضة منك تعلم أنهم ما زالوا يرتدون
أقنعة ما نوع الأحداث التي يقومون بها
ولكن يمكننا أن نتطلع إلى وقت
يكون فيه المرض أشبه
بالإنفلونزا حيث لا يؤدي إلى
تعطيل أشياء مثل التعليم تمامًا
على الرغم من حقيقة أننا  تستمر
في رؤية هذه المتغيرات الجديدة ليست جيدة ،
أحدث ما تعرفه لا يزال هناك بعض
التقييم الذي يتم إجراؤه ،
أنت تعرف ما هي الآثار الصحية
، من الواضح
أننا نعمل على
لقاحات معدلة وأن هناك فرصة جيدة جدًا
سنحتاجها
يبدو أن بعض العلاجات
لا تتأثر ، لذا فإن الإسراع في إخراج هؤلاء
سيحدث فرقًا كبيرًا في
الحد من الوفيات
ولكنك تعلم حتى لو كان علينا صنع
لقاح خاص والحصول على ذلك  لا
أعتقد أنه في عام 2023 ،
سيكون لدينا مستوى الاضطراب
الذي كنا نعرفه خلال السنوات الثلاث الأولى
من هذا